Hi everyone, thank you so much for being here.
I am really excited to be here.
You have a great panel up ahead.
And as I was preparing for it you know it's
called My Society, My Self and I thought well
how did-how did I define myself and I started
thinking you know what is what's the first
question I remember asking myself when I was
young?
And I couldn't remember but I could remember
the earliest questions that others asked me
in the earliest probably, is what's your name?
Right.
How do you define yourself that way.
How old are you?
How old are you little girl?
I remember those as well.
And so it's very interesting that my first
kind of perceptions of self came from questions
that others posed to me.
What do you want to be when you grow up?
That's one that I definitely remember and
I'm still asking myself that.
And these sorts of questions are part of identity,
part of our self.
Part of the really fascinating things that
this panel is going to be talking about and
we have such a great group.
We have perspectives from neuroscience, from
philosophy, from psychology.
So it's going to be a really fascinating way
to get a lot of different insight into what
makes us who we are.
You know what is it that defines human beings?
And what is it that defines how you think
of yourself in your own mind?
So without further ado let's introduce our
panelists.
Our first participant is a wonderful neuroscientist
and she's a professor in the Department of
Psychology and the Zuckerman Mind Brain Behavior
Institute at Columbia.
She researches memory and she studies patients
with brain disorders, Parkinson's, schizophrenia,
eating disorders and her work has yielded
insights into how the brain changes learning
how memories are created and retrieved and
how memory shapes our decisions, our actions,
and ourselves.
So please give a big welcome to the show.
Come our next participant is a philosopher
and he's from the City University of New York.
He's a leader in the field of experimental
philosophy and experimental philosophy, will
talk a little bit about what that is, but
it brings empirical methods to mind on philosophical
questions.
He is the author of several books including
Furnishing the Mind, Gut Reactions and The
Emotional Construction of Morals.
So let's please give a round of applause to
Jesse Prinz.
Also joining us is a post-doctoral fellow
at Yale University.
She has appointments at the School of Management
and the cognitive science program.
She conducts research on moral psychology,
personal identity, and emotion and her recent
work examines how humans create a sense of
continuous identity for themselves and others.
Please welcome Nina Strohminger.
And our final participant is a professor of
psychology philosophy and Linguistics at Yale
University and his work involves using the
kinds of experimental methods associated with
cognitive science to address the kinds of
questions associated with philosophy.
He is the coeditor of the book Experimental
Philosophy.
So please welcome our final participant Joshua
Knobe.
Thank you guys so much for being here today.
And I wanted to start since we're going to
be talking a lot about the self with kind
of the fundamental question, What is the self?
How do you guys think about it?
How do you define it?
So maybe we can start with Josh and work our
way backwards to get to get an insight into
what the self is.
Your question is a really good one and I think
one of the things that we've learned over
these past few years of really trying to study
how people understand the self is that there
isn't a single way that they understand the
self.
It's not as though there's some one the thing
that we could study and way well we're studying
this we're studying how people ordinarily
think of themselves.
Rather people seem to think about the stuff
in a whole variety of different ways, often
varying the way they think about the self
depending on the context.
So for example, something that we've been
interested in our own work is just the idea
that in some cases people think well there
are all sorts of different things that make
up yourself.
All sorts of different emotions, beliefs,
desires, and intentions.
But at other times people end up thinking
about it in a very different way.
They think, no there's something that's the
core of who you really are and your true self.
The thing that you really are deep down inside
and then of course there may be these various
emotions and beliefs that in some sense you
have but those things aren't the real you.
Well I, Josh and I work together so naturally
we agree on everything.
He sort of stole my thunder but I guess I'll
just add to that that the work that actually
most people on this panel have been doing
integrates this view that to philosophers
or people a priori before they've collect
collected any data at all they might say,
well the self is this or that or this other
thing.
But the sort of work that we've been engaged
in actually takes work like uses as its definition
for the self what other people think of the
self as.
So we're not sort of coming down from above
and just giving a definition to it, but rather
saying like well how do ordinary folk and
ordinary folk think about the self and using
that to fuel our theories about it.
Also-let me just add, I mean why are we here
today?
And I think the interest in this show is symptomatic
of a kind of Western individualism.
The very word "self" makes us think about
our own individual strivings and goals.
How do we organize as unique persons isolated
from the rest.
I think that's fundamentally wrong.
I think one thing we're learning about the
self is that the self is really at its core
a social phenomenon.
The reason why we have self, the reason why
we keep track of identity over time is that
we need to relate to others in forming those
bonds, those relationships, those social groups
depends on a certain kind of taxonomy of persons.
So I don't work with any of these folks and
I totally disagree.
No.
But I do have what I think in many ways a
very different perspective as a neuroscientist
and it is a challenging one in the sense that
I think we'd all probably agree that to the
extent that we have a sense of self or there
is a self.
It's not you know there in our knee or our
toes.
It's got to be in our brain and emerging and
related to biological and neural processes.
I think that raises a whole set of questions
and answers that are somewhat parallel or
orthogonal to the perspectives that you guys
mentioned in terms of what does it mean to
have a self?
Is a self a changing entity or not?
And how does it relate to kind of social construction?
But I think you know it helps I think situate
the question of self, thinking about it as
it relates to the brain in the context of
similar questions like, What does it mean
to produce an action in a given moment?
To what extent does each action we produce
represent our self and inform our self?
What does it mean to retrieve a memory of
ourselves?
And so these are the kinds of questions that
I think neuroscience has very specific answers
to.
And I think a big challenge is to is to figure
out how those different slices of behavior
tell us about the self and inform ourselves,
our sense of how the self is constructed.
So let me follow up on that and ask so what-when
you're when you're talking about the self
and neuroscience, what are the sorts of questions
that you think that neuroscience can actually
help us answer?
And then what.
You know I love to hear the reaction of the
rest of the rest of you non-neuroscientist
who all worked together and we'll be speaking
with one voice.
We will get you to disagree.
So I'd love to kind of hear you guys discuss
a little bit about what methods might be appropriate
to what sorts of questions and do we need
all of them to actually figure out what the
self is?
Right maybe you know just start by making
a statement that might sound a little blasphemous
coming from the neuroscientists which is I
think it's really worth asking.
We want to understand the self in a deeper
philosophical societal level.
Should we as a society care a whole lot about
how it's implemented in neurons or circuits
of neurons?
I'm interested in how that happens so for
me that's an easy answer.
And I think media and the presence and at
these sorts of events here suggest that a
lot of people are interested in those questions
but I think we should be very careful about
how we assess neuro-scientific data and it's
relevant to these kind of societal questions.
We also need to remember that neuroscience
is really in its infancy, especially this
level of thinking about brain processes in
healthy human beings and how they are carried
out on a very fine timescale like sitting
here and thinking about questions of the self.
Those are the things we want to get at.
But they're very hard to get at.
I mean you asked about kind of how we can
even start doing that, what are some of the
tools we have.
And we have many, many of the most powerful
tools for understanding the brain.
Historically did not exist in humans.
We can debate and people do whether a sense
of self is a uniquely human phenomenon without
even engaging in that debate I think we're
interested in that aspect of it.
And that limits the tools we have to mostly
two kinds.
And one is looking at patients with brain
damage.
And what that does to their sense of self
and Nina and I were just discussing some of
her work on this topic.
And you know that I think that that that can
be useful.
There are certainly cases of brain damage
impacting, changing people's sense of self.
And again I think what that tells us is mostly
that it's not in the knee or the toe.
It's in the brain.
And then the other tool that I think has really
changed the public and scientific perception
of the role of the brain in many complicated,
interesting phenomena, is human brain imaging.
So we are now in a position and have been
for about 10 to 15 years with increasing power
to put healthy human beings in a brain scanner
and measure where in their brain there is
activity.
None of us think that the self lives in a
particular node in the brain.
So it's a challenge to come up with ways to
ask the right questions.
Given that somewhat blunt tool.
Yes.
So do the experimental philosophers in the
crowd want to actually engage with that and
say, well first of all what is experimental
philosophy?
Let's ask that and then.
Let's ask the author of the textbook.
So experimental philosophy is an attempt to
go after these kinds of questions that we
traditionally associate with philosophy.
But using these kinds of methods, using systematic
experimental studies.
So the kind of thing that Daphna was interested
in is the question, how is it that people
actually engage in certain actions, what behaviors
and so forth?
We could also ask how do people ordinarily
understand the self?
How do people normally think about what it
is to be a self?
How the self extends over time?
How the self is related to our moral identity
and moral responsibility.
What the core of the self is, what's important?
And experimental philosophy involves the experimental
philosophy of the self.
Involves the scientific study of that-the
scientific study of the concepts that people
ordinarily use to understand what the self
is most fundamentally about.
Just adding to that, one question you often
get if you do experimental work but you have
an employer who is in the philosophy department,
you get a lot of resistance I think for people
like us.
We're really interested in questions.
And if you're asking a question you should
never restrict yourself to a single methodology.
For training reasons, it's very often useful
to specialize.
But you should be open to the possibility
that multiple fields can contribute to answering
the questions.
If you're interested in the self, history
can contribute, literature can contribute,
neuroscience can contribute, sociology, anthropology,
philosophy and psychology.
No individual can take on all of those fields
so obviously it's going to be a interdisciplinary
effort, a big conversation.
But the more training you can get in the more
fields, the more resources you have as an
individual to bring to bear on the topic question.
I want to just give one example going back
to Daphna I mean I think with respect to the
self.
A very good case of where these fields have
come together is in some of the experimental
work that I think Nina will talk about.
We really have been finding that morality
is an important part of personal identity.
But what is morality?
Well sociology.
All of those things contribute economics,
but neuroscience has helped us see that moral
responses are connected to certain brain structures.
One of the interesting things about those
brain structures is we know their job profile
outside of the moral domain.
And it seems like they do at least two other
things.
One of them is they're essentially involved
in emotion.
And another is these very same brain structures
some of them like the posterior cingulate,
are also involved in perception of the body.
So here we get this big social theory of the
self coming out of philosophical ideas supported
by psychology, linking cells to morality and
then we get brain science, taking that to
the next stage, linking morality to emotion,
linking emotion to the body and suddenly this
very cultural thing, like moral values gets
grounded in the physical corpus in ways that
we couldn't have really discovered I think
without the kinds of tools that Daphna uses.
Well I want to follow up on that on the point
about emotions.
I think it's very important but I'd actually
love for Nina to talk a little bit about her
experience, because you were trained in psychology
right, in cognitive psychology and now you
are working with the experimental philosophers.
So how you know why did you decide to do that?
And is it driven by the questions or by the
tools you know- how does that work together?
The question is what brought me over to the
dark side.
Well I've always been interested in philosophy
and you know even as an undergrad, I was doing
work in cognitive science which draws a lot
from philosophy as well as psychology in the
brain sciences.
So I never really saw it as a trajectory to
the dark side.
Maybe I always been embedded.
And the decision to go to get my Ph.D. in
psychology was actually largely arbitrary.
I thought maybe there was a marginal, marginally
better chance I would get a job at the end
of it but it wasn't.
I didn't feel like you know I defected at
any point.
So working with philosophers, especially empirically
minded philosophers who care about the experimental
work the scientific work, feels very natural
and it's been very productive as well.
So your sense of self is a very practical
one.
But Jesse, I'd love to.
I'd love to actually follow up on this concept
of emotion and the importance of emotion in
the self because I think it's actually a thread
that runs through all of your work to some
extent because we have you know emotional
memories, and we have emotions, and how they're
impacted.
You mentioned briefly you know Nina's work
on disease and we'll talk a little bit about
that.
Values and moralities.
So I'd love to get your perspective on what
the role of emotions is when it comes to defining
what self is.
Well I mean I think we are phrases like, "I
don't feel myself today" and if you stop and
pause for a minute the idea of feeling like
a self, what does that even mean?
How is the self something that you can feel?
And I think the insight that's captured in
those kinds of clichés is that we really
can in a sort of deep introspective way, recognize
when we're acting in accord with how we normally
act.
And when we depart from that.
And to not feel yourself can be in part emoting
differently, feeling differently.
Things that once stirred you now leave you
apathetic.
Those who have experienced kind of anecdotal
symptoms associated with depression who were
you know had sources of joy who they try to
self-medicate by doing something that they've
found worthwhile in other areas of their live
and find themselves indifferent, are really
discovering a kind of rupture of identity.
So I think in that way we can find a lot of
evidence that emotions are central to what
it is to experience yourself as being the
same person.
How you react emotionally is central to who
you are.
So who would you be a different person if
you suddenly descended into clinical depression?
I think the answer is with Josh's original
comment that the self has many facets and
there is no one thing that is the self.
But I do think when we deal with mental illness,
one of the challenges for people who suffer
it and for family members too is that a lot
of these symptoms are really insults to the
self in ways that need to be recognized.
Depression isn't just feeling down or feeling
incapacitated.
It really is a much more radical shift from
your mode of being.
Another aspect of this is depression is an
emotional style and a lot of us I think who
have sort of symptoms of this kind of emotional
symptoms begin to identify with those symptoms.
So why are so many people reluctant to give
up on their depression or medicate their depression
or get over their depression.
Why do those phrases meet with some resistance?
Part of it is your emotional mode is core
to identity in a way that is threatened by
significant changes even in the positive clinical
directions.
Do any of you guys want to jump in?
I mean I may have found the thing that I disagree
with Jesse about.
Maybe when we talk about a moral determinate,
there is actually no disagreement.
But there is a difference between feeling
like yourself and this question of what the
self feels like from the inside.
And what would make someone else seem like
a different person.
And those two things can come apart.
So in some of my work on patients with different
brain diseases, including depression, depressive
symptoms are quite common with neurodegenerative
diseases.
We find that the extent to which someone is
experiencing or rather is displaying the symptoms
of depression is-doesn't at all predict whether
someone says this is the same person or I
feel like I don't recognize them anymore.
So.
And that was true for other emotional states,
happiness sadness.
So it doesn't seem like emotion is playing
a very big role in determining the identity
of other people, their continuous identity.
Although you probably are right that depression
from the inside really changes how we how
we feel like whether we feel like ourselves.
So actually yeah, please.
So maybe just building on the kind of thing,
you know we're saying.
So traditionally philosophers often suggest
that ultimately the true nature of the self,
the real essence of who we are is our capacity
to reason.
So the thought was that our emotions are just
kind of getting in the way of the self.
If we could only get rid of those emotions
then we'll be able to express who we really
most fundamentally are.
So people will give these examples that are
in many ways I feel seem compelling.
So consider for example someone who is a heroin
addict and when he reasons, he thinks, I have
to kick this, I have to get clean.
But his emotions are driving him to get another
hit.
In this case we would say, oh his true self,
who he really is, is something about his ability
to reason.
It's his- that part of him is strong and toward
getting clean and it's who he really is.
This other thing, his emotions are drawing
him toward.
That's not who he really is.
But I think what we're seeing in a lot of
recent work coming out from Jesse, from Nina,
from many others is that this intuition we
have has actually has nothing to do with the
difference between reason and emotion.
Rather it just has to do with the fact that
we think that heroin is bad and that getting
a-kicking heroin is good.
And I think you could see it really easily
if you just imagined taking the reason and
the emotion and just sort of switching the
roles.
So I suppose there was a high school student
who on reflection thought, I should really
just start doing heroin.
It will increase my social status of being
more popular in school, is going to mean a
really good direction.
But then when she thinks about doing this,
she just has this emotion that draws her to
not do it.
She just kind of feels icky about it.
It just sort of feels wrong to her.
So this sort of states that she has are just
the inverse of the heroin addict that appears
in the traditional philosophical example.
And here I think we would say exactly the
opposite.
We would say, that voice within her, that
feeling of icky-ness or discomfort with doing
heroin.
That's her true self and her capacity to reason
which is telling her to ignore that voice.
That's something she has to get rid of to
get back in touch with who she really is.
So I'd love to.
I can I completely agree and I was thinking
of making a similar point as it emerges from
the neuroscience kind of point of view which
is that we share as humans this intuition
of sort of say, your cognition versus emotion.
One of the really interesting conclusions
from our work on the brain over the past decade
and more is that the brain doesn't respect
those boundaries at all nor really should
it for the reasons you mentioned and so the
idea of thinking of feelings as being separate
from thinking doesn't make sense.
We don't have emotional and kind of rational
parts in our brain that are dueling it out
even though that idea is very compelling and
has been around for a very long time, back
to Aristotle I believe.
Looking at the philosophers for approval.
And so in many ways, it kind of changes the
question we want to ask then is not what is-where
in the brain do these two forces live and
where do they duke it out?
But what are the very specific circuits in
common that they take advantage of and what
are the principles that drive them?
Because the fact is still at the level of
what we do our actions, which I think really
is kind of how the most conservative or useful
way to think the self in many ways.
When we do something we take one action.
We either go for the heroin or not.
We either eat the chocolate cake or resist
it.
And so one of the things we've been really
interested in is understanding not how emotional
loses or wins but what are the circuits that
bias our behavior to reach for something or
not reach for it.
That bias our decision to do something or
not do it.
So it's interesting that there's such convergence.
I wasn't aware of it.
Well I think it's also it's an interesting
question that Josh keeps bringing up of your
quote unquote true self versus kind of your
other self which isn't your true self.
And I'd love for you to talk a little bit
more about that and also how much of that
is actually imposed externally versus how
you really feel about yourself.
So if we give the example of the heroin addict,
does she think that she has a true self and
something that's not a true self or is that
just a judgment that we're making about her?
Well I was going to introduce this topic so
maybe I should hear from some of the other
folks.
Well you're the expert on the true self.
To what extent this kind of thing is this
introduced externally versus something that
appears within our selves?
It seems like initially almost all research
on this notion of the true self was based
on how people think about their own true selves.
And this research would ask Nina about Nina's
true self, Jesse about Jesse's true self,
and Daphna about Daphna's true self.
What this kind of research finds is that people
always thought that their true self is something
really awesome, fantastic, just absolutely
wonderful in every way.
So the more you feel like you're in touch
with your true self, the more you feel that
your life is a meaningful one, the more you
feel that your decisions are on target.
The more you feel like you're doing something
that you're supposed to do.
And it's very easy to dismiss that kind of
result.
You just think, the reason people think so
well of their own true selves is because they
think so well about everything about themselves.
Everyone thinks that they're the best driver,
that they're the easiest to get along with,
almost every single professor at a university
thinks they're above average.
So maybe in just same way people think that
their true self is the really wonderful kind
of true self.
But just in the past few years, people have
been trying this in a different way where
they ask people about the true selves of other
people.
So this time now we ask Nina about Daphna's
true self, Daphna about Jesse's true self,
and Jesse about Nina's true self.
What you find then, is this really extreme
tendency whereby people also think that other
people's true selves are good.
In fact people think not only the true selves
of people they like are good, but that the
true selves of the people they most hate are
good.
Even the most liberal person will think, there's
something within George W. Bush calling him,
his true self speaking to him and saying what
you're doing in Guantanamo is morally wrong.
Deep down it's not what he really is really
being drawn to do.
So there seems to be something about human
beings that makes them think of themselves
as being-having a good true self.
But it's not something about it being your
own self.
It's something that applies equally to how
everyone else will think about your true self.
So it seems like there's some moral judgment
actually that is that is being imposed from
the outside, which is defining true selves
for other people.
So I might think that you know the true self
of someone else is good for a different reason
than you.
We might actually have it backwards.
Absolutely and that actually I mean Josh is
too modest to refer to his own work directly
when he's describing this that he has this
wonderful study where he shows that if you
ask, if you describe this-a case of someone
who is-has homosexual feelings but since he
is highly religious and his religion prescribes
homosexuality he believes that he shouldn't
be gay and then you ask people, which is his
true self?
The drive to be gay that's emotional.
Or the intellectual belief that he ought not
to be gay?
And it turns out that it depends entirely
on whether you ask liberals or conservatives
this question.
So if you yourself believe that it's wrong
to be gay, you say his true self is the part
of telling him not to be gay.
But if you think that it's it's actually a
non-moral issue whether you're gay or not.
Then you say, yeah, his true self are those
emotional drives.
So this actually gets to some of Jesse's work
about the self as being a socially determined
thing.
Can you talk a little bit about kind of that
conception of ourselves coming from our experiences
and socialization.
And I'm was also wondering you know if you
are someone who was raised without a lot of
people around, would you develop a sense of
self in the same way?
Great.
You know I just we have to come back briefly
to Joshua's example of the attribution of
goodness to moral self.
When I recently reread Hannah Arendt's Eichmann
in Jerusalem, which is a very provocative
I think, very problematic book.
But one of the things that really offended
people about that book when she first published
it is the suggestion that Adolf Eichmann was
banal, that there was some way in which he
was just an ordinary bureaucrat who was co-opted
into this diabolical project.
Deprive people of their desire to blame him
by seeing him as an evil self in her early
work on totalitarianism.
She had this idea of radical evil.
Some people are just at their deepest core
bad.
And I think the flip side, the counterpoint
to the general phenomenon you're describing
is in certain contexts, we really do want
to hold people accountable at the core.
And recent work on Eichmann in particular
has come out suggesting that he was very systematic
and non-apologetic Nazi ideologue, which helped
confirm this idea that it wasn't just that
he was pushed around like in the Stanley Milgram
experiment by circumstance but that there
was a driving motivation to engage in the
acts that he perpetrated.
Which of course, that is a social dimension
in the self because it's how we think about
other people's selves, what we want to project
when we talk about ourselves on Facebook and
social networks, we're listing these traits
and we try to list things about ourselves
that will ingratiate us, but also help us
form social groups.
I just was refereeing a paper showing that
if there's a transformation from being a punk
rocker to being a jock.
That's considered a sort of a bad thing.
And that's a sort of a more radical loss of
self than if you go from being a- sorry, punk
rock to jock a good thing.
It's seen as a moral improvement.
If you go from being a jock to a punk rocker,
that's seen as some sort of degeneration.
So we have these things we want to project
to others about social identity.
If you tell somebody you're a punk rocker,
they're immediately going to form all kinds
of associations with you.
But one of the things that happens in these
group membership identities is we form affiliations,
we find like minded people.
So why is it so important on Facebook to say
your political values.
And the answer is you don't want to have any
contact with people who are your political
opposites.
So if you find out the person you're dating
and we have some data on this, belongs to
a different political party.
Even now with like Bernie and Hillary, I've
lost friendships over you know who-which candidate
you support for the Democratic nomination
and that that divide makes it impossible to
form close affiliation.
So when you say, "I'm a Hillary person" or
"I'm a Bernie person," you're saying something
about your identity that bears on who can
be your friend and that that I think is a
deep revelation that the self is not about
me, qua individual, it's about me qua group.
Who are the people who are going to fortify
me in life as part of my extended identity.
So
wouldn't that depend though, on how important
politics were to you personally?
So doesn't it actually depend on the person
and the relative importance of different things
to your sense of self?
So if politics is totally unimportant to me,
I'm not going to lose any friendships over
Bernie supporters.
We thought so.
So with a collaborator, Javier Gomez-Lavin,
we did a series of studies where we gave people
all kinds of traits that might matter to identity.
Occupation, are you urban versus rural, what
are your pastimes, what are your music tastes,
and so on.
Among these we also had politics and religion,
which are very moral dimensions.
And then we ask people how important are these
things to you?
That was one question.
And then if these things change, would you
still be the same person?
For things like musical taste, people tended
to get very high ratings of importance.
Music really matters to me.
Or being urban, or my job really matters to
me, occupation is extremely important to most
people.
But when those things change would you still
be the same person if you change jobs?
If you moved to a small town?
Sure.
Yeah that wouldn't threaten my identity.
Would you be the same person if you change
your political party affiliation?
Would you be the same person if you went to
a different church or adopted maybe went from
being an atheist to a theist?
People say yes.
And strikingly in response to your question,
they say that is a threat to identity or a
change to identity even if in the first question,
they say it isn't very important to them.
So if you find somebody that-Nina has some
data that go in a slightly different direction
on this that are very interesting.
If you find people who say morality doesn't
matter much to me or politics don't matter
much to me.
And say, Ok, so if the next election cycle,
what if you've started voting for the other
side or what have you started really caring
about politics all of a sudden?
Would you be the same?
And people tend to say no.
Nina, do you want to...
Yes.
So we have this data that shows that.
So first of all, we find that the part of
the self that's the most important to saying
that someone is the same person with if you
look at different parts of the mind.
So your memories, your moral capacities, your
personality, your preferences, the things
you like and dislike, basic cognitive capacities.
The factor that matters the most and all the
other factors, they matter a little bit.
The one that matters the most are your moral
values, your moral beliefs, your moral actions.
But if you go to psychopaths, and we have
this data, we say we give people a psychopathy
test, and actually-so you can have someone
who is a clinical psychopath, you can also
have-so everyone in this room would score
slightly different on the psychopathy test.
Presumably there's no one out here who is
like a perfect psychopath.
But there are some natural-
Well it's 1 in 100
So there might be like a perfect 40 in the
audience right now.
But for the most part, there is there's natural
variation.
And people you know who are sort of high but
are subclinical might you know, go into business
or something.
But if you go to these people and you give
them the same sorts of battery of tests, they
no longer show a preference for moral traits.
Which goes against the suggestion that, oh
it's really about maneuvering through the
social world.
Because surely it's very important to psychopaths
to know you know who can they manipulate,
who's gullible and trusting, and so forth.
It really seems like what's going on is they
say, well this is what's important to me.
"Are these moral traits important to me?
No not really I don't value them.
Therefore they're not really important to
the identity of other people either."
I'd love to have...
I actually would like to make a comment and-am
I allowed to ask a question?
Yeah, please.
So the comment is that in studies of things
like decision making and choices.
So again I'm-I keep emphasizing like the actions
people take.
There's a lot of data showing that if you
ask people to choose about say between two
options, either for reward like between a
blue square and a red square and they're going
to get money and they do this 200 times and
as the experimenter, you're controlling how
likely they are to win on any given choice.
People readily engage in this, especially
undergraduates who are excited about getting
the money.
And if you ask them later what they did, they
will come up with a story about how they made
their choices.
But if you look at what they actually did,
it doesn't fit their story.
It fits often a story we have about how the
brain should be driving the actions.
And so I've really come over the years, and
many of my colleagues, to feel like asking
people what they think only tells you what
they think and doesn't necessarily get why
they're doing what they're doing.
And I guess that's a long lead to the question
of, and I ask it kind of naively, do you take
for granted that asking people what they think
makes a self is actually, that those answers
actually tell us what makes a self a self?
Absolutely not.
I think that these, these two are they're
distinct.
But at the same time, the question of what
actually makes a self a self, although it's
a metaphysical question in many ways, it's
not a question that probably could be answered
satisfactorily with any sorts of studies.
I mean I just I agree with Nina and I would
put forth your question but I would say as
a matter of descriptive fact, morality has
this weird kind of tenacity.
There's work by Linda Skitka on what is called
attitude strength.
And it turns out, psychologists measure this
in different ways.
How intensely do you feel about something?
How important is it to you?
And if it were to change, would it be a kind
of loss, how connected is it to your other
core, stabilizing values?
She found that morality was the only thing
that showed up as correlated across all measures
of attitude and strength very consistently.
There are also studies of political party
affiliation in the US over the lifespan.
Within a 40 year span, the variation is about
six people remain the same to about the degree
of 65 percent.
So within basically a whole voting life from
your earliest elections to you know older
ages, you're voting pretty similarly, despite
dramatic changes that might be taking place
in your society.
If you look at 10 year periods, it's about
80 percent.
Take the big five personality traits, the
most validated traits of personality that
have ever been studied.
Openness, conscientiousness, extroversion,
neuroticism and agreeableness.
Those are less stable.
They're very stable, but you can look at say
5, 10 year intervals and in some studies,
the agreement over those times is again in
the 60 something percentile for fairly short
periods.
Over the lifespan, that can drop off precipitously
and very susceptible to dramatic life changes.
Political values, which is an indirect sort
of measure of moral attitudes, do show a kind
of tenacity that I think is unusual among
our traits.
So one of the things that I'd love for Daphna
to talk about since I think the three of you
have been emphasizing morality as kind of
the most important thing.
And Daphna obviously studies memory.
And I'm curious about your thoughts on whether
memory might be more important than morality
to us?
Well I would have to put it as a competition
between them.
I think for me somebody who studies memory,
I think the point I'd want to make in the
allotted time is that memory is much more
fundamental to our behaviors in general than
we think.
It's not just our ability to remember something
we did yesterday.
But is that many of our actions if not every
single one is informed by past experience,
one way or another.
And I think that's a very interesting an interesting
challenge is to understand how that emerges.
It makes sense for a brain and a being to
take advantage of our past experiences and
use them and so the key question I'm interested
in is exactly how that happens.
So I think memory is fundamental to many aspects
of our behaviors, including our sense of self.
And one of the biggest questions then is how
as for us as neuroscientists where we're just
in many ways starting out.
We know a pretty solid amount about the likelihood
for any one of us at any given moment that
will remember a particular event.
OK so we know a lot about how an individual
memory is formed and then retrieved.
I think the interesting intersection between
memory and sense of self starts when we try
to understand how those memories get connected
over time.
And we can think from the memory angle on
the self as a self as being sort of emerging
as a interrelated with the memories as they
unfold over a lifetime.
So we're you know as a scientist of the brain,
we now can say what happens with a single
memory, maybe with two or three memories.
And we know that a big job that the parts
of our brain that form memories, one of the
big challenges is that they are constantly
weaving our memories into a network.
We'd like to think that that network is on
one hand gives rise to a sense of self, but
we also know and I think it's important to
emphasize the other direction, that we are-our
sense of expectations about the world.
I don't know if you count that as self, but
there the way we perceive the world will also
change the way our memories are formed.
So memories are very personal in that sense.
They're absolutely not just a veridical record
of what happened in a given moment or our
lives.
Their influenced heavily by what we expected
would happen and those expectations are shaped
by the memories we had before them.
So I think there is this that there is an
interesting role for memory.
I don't you know, I don't think of it personally
as being in competition with morality per
se.
But I don't study morality so that might be
why.
Well I would actually suggest that this work
is not encompassing of what you're saying
with what you're saying in a very different
sense.
So what the three of us have been studying
is the question, how do people ordinarily
understand the self?
And then that's a very different question
from understanding how it is that human beings
actually perform actions?
So I feel like, suppose that we found that
people who ordinarily understand the self
as being considered in such way that some
certain thing is the most fundamental thing
and then you found that in fact, that thing
just is the thing that most fundamentally
guides people's actions.
In a way I think that would make our discovery
less interesting because then it wouldn't
be that surprising that people would think
that's most fundamental, because it just simply
is what's most fundamental.
What would make-what would be most surprising
on the part of the- for us to discover is
if people seem to all be converging on something
that's the absolutely most fundamental part
of the self.
But then when neuroscientists actually begin
to study it, they found that plays little
role, if anything.
So it seems like far from being there being
a competition if we find different things,
it seems like it would make the work all the
more exciting.
If these different kinds of research programs
ended up finding different things as beings
what's at the core.
I think that's largely what's happened in
my opinion with consciousness to some extent.
It's interesting.
We all think it's interesting.
We all read about it and wonder about it.
One of the findings emerging from neuroscience
and cognitive neuroscience and cognitive psychology
is that it appears to play much less important
a role in many of our actions and behaviors
and even reasoning than we thought it did.
Right so suppose that people who study how
people ordinarily think about consciousness
found that the way people ordinarily think
about consciousness is exactly the way that
you think that the consciousness actually
works.
Then the study of how people ordinarily think
about consciousness would be a slightly tedious
research program.
By contrast, suppose that you discover how
consciousness actually plays a role in people's
actions and then people studying how people
think about consciousness find that it plays
a rad-it plays a radically different role
in people's ordinary conception of their actions.
Then things become interesting.
We have to ask, how do people come to have
this conception of their actions that so radically
departs from what our sense is telling us?
Well it's just-sorry, Jesse.
Nina if you want to talk a little bit about
the memory moral contract that's come out
in some of your work.
Oh well I guess I mentioned it in passing
before.
But when we-when you ask-so you could give
people a scenario where you say imagine that
it's the not too distant future and this man
Jim, he gets into a car accident and the doctors
give him a little microchip to replace the
part of his brain that gets damaged.
And then they do all these detailed tests
and psychological measures to see if he's
OK and they find one of the following things:
they either find that he's psychologically
normal, no change, or they find that he lost
all of his memories from before the accident,
or they find that he's lost his moral compass,
he no longer knows the difference between
right and wrong.
And we've a few other conditions and we find
that if he's lost all his memories from before
the accident, people say that's much less
important to the question of whether Jim is
the same person now as before, as if he's
lost his moral compass.
So certainly for folk judgments about the
nature of personal identity, morality plays
a much larger role than memories, even if
it ends up not being the case for what actually
drives behavior.
When we when we first discovered this, it
really was striking from the perspective of
someone trained in philosophy.
If you study the theme of personal identity
and philosophy, the starting point is John
Locke.
In 1690, he wrote a book that really was the
book about the mind for the next 200 years.
And in that, he was a very seminal discussion
of what makes you the same person over time.
And it's a bit difficult to interpret this
whole text.
What's the view.
But it does look from his examples, like memory
is the key.
What makes me the same person over time is
that I can recall my past.
I can bring up these past episodes in my mind.
So when we started to ask ordinary people
what they think about this, and Nina has done
really at this point a couple of dozen, dozens
of experiments we have asking this question.
They tend to think memory isn't that important.
It could be a fanciful case or a very real
world case.
We all have relatives who have suffered from
memory loss through aging and we have to ask
is it the same person?
And in all of this work, we find memory loss
does impact our sense of this being the loved
one we've always had.
But not to the same degree as change in values.
Of all the things we've measured, and we keep
trying new things, morality just continues
to show up as the trait for which identity
is framed.
It really looks like the one that's most crucial.
If you imagine an older relative whose values
start to change dramatically.
That looks like they're less of the same person
than an older relative who's lost memory.
And to me that really is the kind of discovery
that even though it's common sense that we're
proving, all of our training and what identity
is has sort of gotten us to look past this
core feature that's now emerging empirically
as central to the self.
It's a great example of the value of experimental
philosophy.
Right?
Because for centuries, philosophers were focused
in on this one trait and as Jesse said, they're
just looking past what actually is going on.
John Locke had this one intuition that might
not be shared by you know the majority of
humanity.
Surprise, surprise philosophy.
But it might be the relevant one for how people
actually make decisions.
And I'm not you know I'm not sure I think
I think you know as Josh was saying earlier,
these are slightly different angles on the
same question that are likely to disagree
in interesting ways.
And I guess you know one of my questions would
be why do we think that morality is not related
to memory.
I think one of the things I'd say is that
memory really informs a lot of behaviors,
even when we're not aware that it does.
So the idea that even moral that moral judgments
are not guided by or informed by memory also
seems at least a question I think.
Can I-I just want to push on this point that
you're making a little bit.
So if you take someone who has radical memory
loss like H.M. or other sort of famous amnesic
cases, is it not the case that they generally
have the same moral character as before?
It's a little bit debatable actually.
The original reports on people- so H.M. so
H.M. is a very famous patient who suffered
memory loss and had an absolutely transformative
effect on our understanding of memory and
the brain.
He had a very severe case of epilepsy that
could not be treated pharmacologically with
medical treatments, drug treatments, and so
they performed surgery on him when he was
in his late 20s and removed the focus of where
the epileptic seizures were taking place.
And that location often in epilepsy, is in
an area called the hippocampus which is kind
of on the side of the brain inside the center
of the medial temporal lobe.
The good news was that that surgical treatments
helped cure the epilepsy.
The unexpected bad news was that H.M. was
no longer able to form new memories.
So he didn't really lose memories from the
lifetime.
But the doctor would come in every day and
every day H.M. didn't recognize the doctor.
And if you try to probe H.M. to remember what
he did yesterday and tell you about it.
He couldn't.
He couldn't create new memories after losing
this part of the brain.
And this was scientifically astonishing because
most of the theories in neuroscience until
that point about localization of memory and
the brain go back to the previous century,
had indicated from animal research that memories
are not in one part of the brain, they're
distributed all over.
And what happened to H.M revealed that no,
actually it is one part of the brain that
seems to be important, crucially important
for one kind of memory which is kind of creating
a record of what we would typically think
of memory.
What you had for breakfast yesterday.
Sorry, kind of went into teaching mode.
The very interesting thing has happened with
H.M. and it's actually exciting to have the
opportunity talk about a H.M. today because
one of the most famous scientists who interrogated
H.M.'s memory over a lifetime was Sue Corkin
from MIT and she passed away about a week
ago and H.M. passed away several years ago
and so anybody who's interested, there's a
lot to read about it.
And Sue Corkin did amazing work and kept on
interrogating him, and doing research on his
memory.
And that's turned out to be really interesting,
because the first passed result led to the
consensus that this part of the brain was
specialized for what people call declarative
memory.
Is the ability to remember what happened yesterday
or the day before and that everything else
was intact, like imagination and creativity
and morality and so forth.
Over the years, that turned out to not be
true.
And that there were a lot of other more subtle
changes in H.M.'s behavior and since then,
we have many more people that have damage
to the hippocampus because of hypoxia or encephalitis,
various other situations.
And these people suffer, many of them from
memory loss.
But understanding that what that memory is
turns out to be much more complicated.
And one example that I think is related potentially
to morality, although again you know I don't
know, tell me what you think, is that if you
just ask people to imagine a scenario, a hypothetical
scenario which it sounds like often happens
in sort of assessments of moral judgments,
that without a hippocampus, people don't imagine
that scenario in the same way.
They imagine it in a very impoverished way.
So if I just asked you I imagine this event
is unfolding in two years.
Tell me about it.
It's your-it's your birthday in two years.
Most of us go into a lot of detail and apparently
vividly imagine it.
People with damage to the hippocampus, which
our textbooks tell us is just memory, don't
imagine that in detail at all.
They give a very, very vague kind of sense
of what's going to happen.
And so I think that's relevant here just for
thinking about memory as playing into something
that you know it had no business playing into
based on the way we understood things initially
from H.M., which I imagine, here you can tell
me that I'm wrong.
Must be important for things like moral judgments.
A couple of brief comments one first, very
much in agreement.
A former student of mine named Felipe De Brigard
who's now a professor of neuroscience and
philosophy at Duke wrote a dissertation where
he asked the question, what is memory for?
And we all might think that's obvious.
Memory is for remembering.
It's for recalling the past.
But what function does it have in evolutionary
terms to revisit all these episodes.
Is nostalgia that useful evolutionarily?
And the answer that he arrived at really systematizing
a lot of trends in the memory literature that
you're involved with.
Is that memory is about the future, not the
past.
Memory is really about planning.
It's about using our past to make decisions
about how to act in the future.
Deprive someone of memory and that will be
impaired.
I had ended(?) whole thing as a colleague
for number of years who was one of the pioneers
studying this kind of memory and studying-worked
with H.M. and other patients with amnesia.
And I asked Tobin(?) you know does H.M. really
have a moral life?
And his answer at the time, just based on
conversations was that there's a way in which
his sense of his life is very superficial.
You ask any of us what's-what is your life
about?
What are your projects?
What are you in this for?
Camus begins one of his books saying the most
important philosophical question is suicide.
Why do we go on?
Life has no meaning so why bother?
Why face tomorrow?
And I think all of us can reflect on that
question deeply in ways that are informed
by our past.
And that's part of our morality, our decisions,
what kind of person I want to be can guide
my sense of meaning in life.
I think for somebody who doesn't have access
to the past, that's going to be limited and
the kind of answer that I think that H.M.
would give to Camus's questions would look
very different than the kinds of answers that
we would all give.
So I do agree morality just as you pointed
out, that reason and emotion are not separated
in the brain.
I think memory and morality are not fundamentally
separated in the brain.
I also agree, but I also have something that
I'd like to add.
This is reminding me of which is this old
Oliver Sacks essay and I know there was a
tribute to him at this festival earlier this
week.
And he wrote this wonderful essay, if you
haven't read it, you should go out and just
leave the festival right now and read it right
now.
It's called The Lost Mariner where he discusses
a patient with Korsakoff's syndrome and people
who are familiar with Sacks' work will know
that one question that he was really obsessed
with is the question of personal identity.
And this whole essay is about this man with
Korsakoff's syndrome.
Korsakoff's syndrome is the result of being
an alcoholic after many years.
I think it's a vitamin B deficiency.
The temporal lobes just disintegrate.
And this patient, Jimmy, he had completely
lost not only his ability to form new memories
but also almost all of his memories from the
past as well.
And so he lived in this sort of bizarre sort
of world where you couldn't live in the past,
he couldn't plan for the future, and he was
really only barely hanging on by a thread
in the present.
And so the question that Sacks interrogates
is, so is Jimmy the same person?
Or in what sense does he have any kind of
identity at all?
And the beginning part-just you know spoiler
alert, I going to tell you what happens in
this essay.
He's really obsessed with this idea that you
know memories really are preventing Jimmy
from truly existing in any real sense.
But then he, in a twist, he observes Jimmy
taking the sacrament at church and he sees
how he's transcended, sees how he reacts to
the holy music, and how he acts when he's
praying and he says Jimmy is not a spiritual
casualty at all.
Since he could still be moved morally and
religiously and spiritually, he still very
much existed.
And the fact that you know he doesn't have
his memory traces anymore, but that's just
you know that's just machinery.
That's not who he really is.
And so he absolutely has survived despite
this devastating brain damage.
So it would say that his true self is still
there.
You might say, you might say...
You might say that but not only might say
that, but that's the sort of key finding coming
out of Nina's work about people who have neurodegenerative
diseases.
Those who lose their memories, they're supposed
to still...
Right.
So if you go to people's families who suffered
brain damage and you ask them about what are
the symptoms that this that the patient has
experienced?
And also you know do they seem like a stranger
to you?
Do you feel like you still know who they are?
Do they seem like the same person deep down
or not?
And then you build a big fancy model.
What you find is the extent- and I think that
Jesse alluded to this earlier, the extent
to which at least people are observing memory
loss actually doesn't predict at all whether
you think this person has changed or not.
The almost the only thing that matters is
the extent to which their moral capacities
have changed.
The one, the one symptom that we found also
made an independent contribution to identity.
We weren't expecting it all.
No philosophers or really almost any kind
of psychologists predicted this.
And so we were also surprised that there is
a smaller but still significant effect of
loss of language.
So if you have a loved one who can no longer
speak or speak fluently with the patient,
this is having a significant effect and whether
you would say it's the same person.
We thought that was really interesting because
language just hasn't-really been absent from
the discussion in literature.
Well one of the things that you keep saying
though, is others think of them as the same
person.
What about themselves?
You know if you are experiencing dementia,
do you still see yourself as the same person
or is your fundamental sense of self altered?
And I know that if you know there is work
and if you ask people this question before
they experience any changes, a lot of people
will say you know I don't want that to happen.
And a lot of people are still able to make
decisions, end of life decisions when they
are in the early stages of dementia.
There have been some really lovely pieces
of writing on people who said, "I'm committing
suicide here because I'm losing part of myself
every single day.
This is when I can still make the decision.
So I'm going to end my life."
And they do.
So it seems that to them, even though to other
people, other people might not agree that
they still think that you're in there somewhere.
You don't agree.
You think that you are being lost.
I think it's a very interesting dichotomy
if you're if you're talking about the self
as external versus the self as perceived by
you.
And it's really tricky methodologically if
you are trying to you know if you're trying
to compare say what's the effect of memory
loss versus morality or any other cognitive
capacity on your own sense of personal continuity
for a few reasons.
We would love to just run this study again
on the patients themselves.
There's a few problems.
One is, when you lose your memories, you begin
to forget who you used to be.
Another problem which might be even an even
bigger problem is that most people with different
forms of dementia don't know that they're
sick.
Especially past the very early stages.
So if you ask them, "Are you the same person
as before or even do you have a disease?"
They say, "no I'm fine.
Nothing's wrong."
So it becomes very difficult to figure out
what's actually going on because people are
no longer able to refer in an objective way
to the person that they once were.
I mean this is something that I was thinking
about obviously with Muhammad Ali's death
that he was the same person that Muhammad
Ali we all knew?
And I know you study Parkinson's.
So it would be interesting to me that is there
a tipping point you know where-where people
lose themselves?
It's an interesting question, especially since
I think what you know is coming out of this
discussion is well are they losing their sense
of themselves?
Are their family losing them, their sense
of self?
Are their actions and decisions actually changing
or not?
Right so these are all different measures
and they don't have to agree.
Parkinson's disease is in many ways particularly
scientifically interesting disease in the
sense that-that the main thing that happens
in Parkinson's disease is a loss of dopamine
neurons in the mid brain that project to a
target called the striatum.
And so that's something that's been known
for a while.
What's been interesting is the discovery that
when people show up with the very first mildest,
earliest symptoms of Parkinson's disease,
they've already lost 70 to 80 percent of those
neurons.
So that tells us something we don't really
know how to interpret well about redundancy
at least in this in this particular circuit.
And just the question of tipping point suggests
that at least in terms of the brain circuit,
there is a tipping point for motor control.
Those are the symptoms that people show up
with.
A lot of the work we've done has to look-has
been looking at how about that loss of dopamine
changes people's ability to sort of gradually
learn associations over time.
This is interesting to us because it's a form
of learning that's very different from what
we would typically call memory.
This has nothing to do with what you did yesterday
and this is the kind of learning that patients
like H.M. typically are pretty much OK with
and depend on memory.
And you know that it's very hard for me to
relate that to self in any kind of meaningful
way without getting completely lost in speculation.
And you know what we have done, we have some
data on how people do, people with Parkinson's,
do this sort of implicit learning and how
well their families seem to think they're
functioning and how much they think they've
changed.
And those two things do seem to go together
so that the family's perception of how motivated
a patient with Parkinson's is to engage in
everyday life seems to be somewhat related
at least to how well they do on this very
kind of boring lab kind of experiment or measurement.
Just to comment on Ali in this particular
case, I think the tragedy of seeing his degeneration,
has different loci.
And one of them has to do with seeing this
incredible athlete who's lost that physical
control.
But I think much more devastating, much more
profound for those who were admirers of Ali,
is that he had been this tremendous force
in civil rights.
I mean he was an extraordinarily courageous
civil rights leader.
And to see that outspoken, articulate, brilliant
leader enter a phase in life where he could
no longer do that.
We all know people who live in athletics or
in dance or other physically demanding careers
won't be able to sustain that.
But we might expect that kind of leadership
to be sustainable.
And I think the you know the ravages that
he experienced through Parkinson's probably
prevented that to some degree.
There's some apathy associated with Parkinson's,
through some depression.
Associated with Parkinson's some impact on
memory.
So all of those things are really limiting
the social position he can play with respect
to leadership.
And for me anyway and I think for many others,
that was the most sad, the most the most significant
shift in who he was as a public persona.
Can I come back to this issue you were talking
about earlier.
So you know back at the beginning of our discussion,
Jesse was suggesting this idea that the self
is attached to some thing social, to our connection
with other people.
But then there was sort of a fight brewing
because Nina was suggesting maybe it's not
in the sense that people with psychopathy
could recognize the same sort of social impact
but wouldn't have the same kind of intuition
about the self.
So I feel like I really regret that we didn't
really get to continue the fight.
I just want to see, what do you what do you
guys things further about this?
Well part of the issue is that the jury's
still out and since I mean I don't have a
dog in this fight.
So however the data turn out is what will
be where I end up you know laying my chips.
But that being said, I don't know when you
bet you can lay your chips after the bet.
It does seem-so one way of sort of rectifying
this or like bringing these two things together
is to think maybe there is a proximate level
or the level of the mechanism.
And that's the part that's getting disrupt-that's
instantiated maybe just as you think within
yourself, well what do I value?
And then I'll say that that applies to other
people's identity of what's important for
them.
But maybe at a more an ultimate functional
or even evolutionary level, it-the whole reason
why this mechanism was put in place or set
into motion is because we care about social
relationships so much.
And actually in some new studies that we have,
when you make you know one of these big fancy
models again and we pit- so if you ask an
individual about you know how much would their
identity change?
But then we also ask a bunch of other questions.
How much would your social relationship with
someone change if this trait changed?
How much how much do you value this?
How much do you think is related to morality
and so forth.
What you find is actually all of these things
matter a little bit.
And social relationships actually also matter
at least when you when you're asking about
judgments.
So it's not I don't think the two are necessarily
in competition.
I mean I like coming back to Josh's opening
comment.
I do think we need to recognize that identity
is a construction.
Maria used that word.
I'm a social construction.
So in the science world, there's the science
fans and then there is social constructionists.
And they're supposed to sort of not get along.
I'm a science grounded social constructionist
and partly because I think science is in the
business of construction.
So take the periodic table of the elements.
It's supposed to be the most fundamental description
of the stuff that makes up the universe or
a bit more fundamental but so what are these
elements?
Well you could organize them by atomic weight.
You could organize them by atomic number.
You could include elements that actually exist
in the real world or ones that don't, merely
hypothetical elements, or lab created elements.
You could include isotopes.
You could include ions.
All these decisions need to be made.
So it's considered elemental is actually a
set of arbitrary decisions.
Not completely arbitrary.
These are real things.
But the way you describe the fundamental building
blocks of reality has a lot of degrees of
freedom.
The way we describe human identity has a lot
of degrees of freedom.
And if you talk about so being a mother.
Being a mother could be a matter of biological
connectedness or it could be a matter of playing
a social role.
Could a man be a mother?
Could an adoptive parent be a mother?
Those are questions that we get to settle
by decision.
We get to settle questions of gender by decision,
questions of race by decision.
And I think questions of personal identity
also by decision.
And because it's based on decision, context
matters.
There's work on how genes are defined in science
depends on the subfield.
If you're in behavioral genetics it may work
differently than in some branches of molecular
genetics.
So I think we need to recognize that for many
of our purposes, morality might be very important
for bookkeeping in human identity.
For others, memory might be important.
For others, various cognitive capacities may
be important.
All of these things are equally real.
All of them matter.
But we get to decide given a goal which one
matters most.
Well I think that's a very good point on which
to end this part of the discussion.
Let's first give you guys a huge hand.
We will open it up to you guys to ask your
questions.
And there will be two mikes that will be traveling
around.
Yes.
Up here.
Hold on please wait for the mike before asking
the question.
Thank you for a great presentation.
Now how, do you Jesse, define morality?
What are the basic constituents of that?
I think we need another hour for that.
That's a big and hard question.
I've come to think that morality is very connected
to emotions, which is something I alluded
to at the beginning but didn't explain.
So we have various different kinds of beliefs
about the world.
Some of them are just you know factual beliefs.
Dinosaurs are extinct.
Aardvarks are marked nocturnal.
Others are evaluative beliefs.
And these include aesthetic values.
This painting is beautiful.
This one is ugly.
Preference is for food, for friendship.
Moral values are among these values and I
think the difference between fact and value,
psychologically, is that values, expressions
of a preference of desire of beauty, but also
of right and wrong fundamentally come down
to our feelings about things.
So this is an old idea associated with people
like David Hume in The History of Philosophy
that says morality is really an expression
of deeply socialized, strongly felt feelings.
So when we train our children to be moral,
when we train our communities to be moral,
we're trying to encourage them to be outraged
at injustice.
To feel disgusted in criminality, to feel
pride and delight in generosity.
It's all about the emotions.
It's a very controversial view.
Yeah, back there.
Hi.
So I think that the question that I have for
the gentleman with the awesome hair.
All of you.
When you were talking about projecting out
if your if your values, your political values
for example change in the future that that
would be a big change of self.
And I think there's a lot of research that
shows that we are we believe we will act more
ideally further from now.
We can take into account all of our every
day small decisions.
So the question is, have you done research
where you look at people who've had big maybe
political or ideological shifts and then ask
them, "have you changed?
Has your inner self changed?"
And do they just simply rationalize it with
language that yeah my large moral ideals have
changed, but I'm still the same person?
That's such a great question.
The short answer is no and we'd love to-and
it's sort of on the on the agenda.
It's difficult research to do partially because
of finding a big enough sample of people who
have undergone those changes in an independent
way to measure that they have in fact undergone
those changes.
I-one of the things that got me interested
in this topic, I started thinking about the
concept of moral death.
So we think about this and dramatic changes
so that most of the neo- the architects of
neo- conservatism began as really left wing
liberal.
And then they-so what happens what happens
there?
Are they the same people?
Was Patty Hearst the same person when she
was so-called brainwashed?
When people undergo religious transformation.
So consider the newborn Christian phenomenon.
Is that really a kind of death of an old self
and a beginning of a new self?
We know that from a third person perspective,
people judge these things to be changes in
identity.
We know from first person perspective hypothetically,
when people are asked if you change in this
way, would you be the same person?
We tend to say no.
But to actually interview people who have
undergone those transformations is a very
I think logical and exciting direction for
us to move.
So you're really anticipating where we where
we want to end up.
So
hopefully the next panel will have an answer
to that question.
So back there?
Around the era that cognitive science was
born, there was a lot of debate in the United
States as Eastern traditions found a way in
as to whether the self was fundamental or
not, whether we could deconstruct the self,
whether the self could even disappear, which
was sort of an aspiration within at least
folk psychology of many Eastern traditions.
And I wonder whether-most of what you talked
about seems to be about what aspects of the
self seem to be malleable.
But I wondered whether there is any of your
research that reflects upon this question
about whether the self can be dismantled either
for a short period of time or in some extended
way?
Yeah.
So I have some work with the philosopher Shaun
Nichols and Jay Garfield where we go to Tibet
and look at Buddhists and now Buddhist-in
Buddhism, there is the doctrine of no self.
Where what this tenet says is that the-you
might think that we have a self that persists
over time, but this is just an illusion.
There really isn't a self in any meaningful
sense.
And this is a doctrine in part that's meant
to have these positive consequences.
So as soon as you let go of this sense of
self, you won't be selfish anymore.
Right?
Because there really is no distinction between
you or other people.
You would be more generous.
And also you should be less afraid of death
because you'll understand that death isn't
anything special.
The death of the physical body because the
self is you know being destroyed in its own
way continuously over a biological life as
well.
And there's nothing actually all that special
about the death of the physical body.
Now so we run into this research thinking
that we were going to find this and that the
Buddhists were going to be so enlightened
about these issues and it turns out we found
two things.
First, we found actually Buddhists are more
afraid of death.
Specifically, they're more afraid of the destruction
of the self.
So if you give them like a bunch of different
why are you afraid of death?
They are terrified of the idea of themselves
being destroyed at death.
And so this paradoxical effect.
And there's another paradoxical effect.
We give them a generosity task essentially.
Would you give some lifesaving medicine to
other people or how much longer would they
need to live in order for you to agree to
give over your medicine to them if you are
also going to die?
And we find that- there are comparison classes
with American subjects and also Indian subjects
who are Hindu and we find that the Americans
and Indians, I mean everyone's selfish right.
No one says oh I'll just give away my pill.
But the but the Tibetan Buddhists they and
they're like, "No way I'm not going to."
Not-in fact two thirds of these- and these
are Lamas too.
They're in you know school to be trained to
be priests.
That two thirds of them say there's no amount
of time that this other person could live
that I would give my medicine over to them.
So one possible-we were you know we were sort
of blown away by this.
One possible explanation though is this relentless
focusing on you know how the self is always
being destroyed is actually quite terrifying.
And that just sort of makes people even more
like reactive and attached to the self.
So it's possible although the jury's still
out, it's possible that this might not even
be a worthy goal to try to destroy this illusion
of the self, even though it might be you know
very much an illusion.
So Josh I was wondering could you ever destroy
the true self?
Or is that something that's not destroyable?
it's an interesting question.
So people seem to have this intuition that
the true self is in some bizarre sense immutable.
So people seem to have the feeling that whatever
is my true self at this moment, it will be
my true self until the time that I die.
It was my true self from the moment that I
was born.
Of course, I could have these changes on the
surface where something that I had that sort
of appeared to me, what I was like shifts
to something else.
But those surface changes seem like they're
just sort of illusions that appears from the
top of the water.
But there's some deeper thing that sort of
remaining constant the whole time.
Of course it's very unlikely that scientific
study of the self will show that there is
such a thing but people really do think that.
Maybe along the lines of the Hindu conception
that these Buddhists are attacking.
We spoke previously about the almost separateness
between memory and morality.
In the experiment that Nina mentioned with
the Jim, the car accident sufferer.
And I wonder if, I mean morality, the moral
the moral compass is essentially the difference
between right and wrong, which requires a
memory of what is right and what is wrong.
A kind of mnemonics schemata that you apply
over the course of time and I wonder if it's
possible that there's a sort of memory based
fabric underneath morality.
And if so, how can that be tested empirically?
Daphna, do you want to?
Well that's, I agree.
In the sense that I think I think there are
sort of memory fabric beneath almost many
of our behaviors of that sort.
I think you know that general statement is
very hard to test and I think that you know
the fact that Nina brought up patient H.M.
is really useful for that.
I actually think that the data from people
with dementia is less informative for this
question in the sense that we know that what
dementia does, like what happened to H.M.,
is the inability to create new memories.
But people with dementia remember most of
their memories from a lifetime.
So one would think that those might be the
most informative.
There are some studies for example kind of
bolstering this perspective, right, that leaders
tend to make decisions about real world crises
and events that are heavily biased by one
event that happened when they were at a critical
period of their life.
So there's a lot of memory-a lot of research
showing that events that happened in our late
teens, early 20s to ourselves and to the world
around us have a very large disproportionate
effect on how we think of what is the best
decision later on.
I don't know if that's been done in the moral
context or not but that would be one way to
start getting at this with studies looking
at kind of how moral judgments later in life
are impacted by events in different phases.
I agree.
I mean I think there are potentially ways
to get an empirically-like looking at a H.M.,
people like H.M. who had not been tested on
standard scales things like psychopathy, which
look at sensitivity to the moral domain.
So that would be a very straightforward way
to do it.
But I think there is so much evidence in life
that these things are connected.
If people in this room are all old enough
to recall the out come of the verdict of the
O.J. Simpson trial.
For African-Americans, the idea that evidence
had been planted was so credible and so vivid
that the verdict-an acquittal in that case
would seem like a just decision.
For a white population who are oblivious to
sort of systemic harassment of various kinds
from law enforcement, an acquittal would be
a case of injustice.
And so how do you make those decisions?
A life long of experiences with people in
law enforcement, with members of a community
who had such encounters inform that decision
very, very important ways.
So I think moral understanding of flip, in
this case, opposite moral intuitions about
the same case are clearly showing the effect
of memory here.
There's a hand way in the back on that side.
Hi, so I wrote this down so I wouldn't forget.
For something like narrative structures which
seem to be obviously like a human construction,
I don't know maybe I'm wrong, but has that
in any way been imprinted neurologically over
time?
It's a great question.
There's a lot to say about it.
But just let me give you one simple example
that speaks to narrative in memory.
There has been work by Jeff Sachs and Lila
Davachi, who's actually here at NYU, showing
that the way our brain organizes memories
is influenced by narrative in the sense of
taking advantage of boundary shifts.
So you can tell a story and connect one part
of the story to the other part of the story
with the word "and' or you can tell a story
where instead of the "and" there is an "and
then" or something like that that implies
a pause.
And that the brain then kind of is more likely
to group together the events that happened
in one part of the narrative separate from
the other part of the narrative based on these
kind of hints on the narrative structure.
Just a quick addition to that, in philosophy
there is a personal identity mostly involving
memory.
But the next most popular theory of that,
after that is a narrative theory which says,
what makes me the same person over time is
my capacity to weave a kind of life story
together.
So with Shaun Nichols, we did a study to probe
ordinary intuitions about this.
So we ask people to imagine somebody who could
still draw memories from the past but couldn't
organize them into a coherent narrative.
Maybe by using their capacities that Daphna
just described.
Would he be the same person?
If you can't organize your life into a story,
are you the same person?
And overwhelmingly, we found that people answered
yes, that losing your narrative capacity is
not a threat to the self.
It's not much of a threat at all and certainly
not nearly as much of a threat as losing your
moral values.
One by one, we've gone through theories of
personal identity from philosophy and shown
that none of them explains ordinary judgment
as much as continuity in morals.
Yes the lady in the middle with the T-shirt.
Thanks so much for just engaging each other
and us in a really interesting discussion.
I was particularly interested by something
that you said Jesse, that in kind of looking
at sort of the neural correlates of morality
based decisions, they involve like really
emotional areas of the brain.
What like how-kind of in sort of like historical
evolutionary brain development, how old or
new are those areas?
How human specific are they?
Good question.
I think they're very well concerned.
In fact I think the-much of the much of the
neocortex is well conserved across mammalian
phyla.
So most-I mean you can use rats as models
for studies of just about every human psychiatric
disorder just because there's so much conservation.
There are important differences, many of them
are not well understood even if you take great
apes, you can see things like the laminar
structure the layers of cells in visual areas
which are very important for for primate cognition
are different than human beings.
So there are differences.
But I think that differences on are greatly
outweighed by the similarities.
So the brain areas that get involved, orbital
frontal areas like Broadmann areas 9 and 10
which are sort of right here if you drive
your fingers through your head.
Temporal pole, which if you drive your fingers
through your temples, the entirety of cingulate
cortex, which is one of the oldest areas of
the cortex which in the middle of the brain.
Is just this, if you know what the corpus
collosum is, the bit that holds the hemispheres
together and allows for communication.
The bit of cortex that surrounds that comes
up in a lot of these studies.
One area that might be a difference maker,
the superior tempora sulcus, which is very
involved in aspects of social cognition like
attributing mental states to others is another
big player in world cognition.
These structures do have homologs in primates
at least.
But we do know that our capacity to use these
structures to engage in high levels of social
cognition is appreciably greater.
So there is some possibility that there are
some distinctive human capacities involved
in morality.
I would say that non-human animals probably
don't have more rules in the way that we do.
Partially because they lack this aspect of
social cognition.
The really rich sense of how is this going
to make someone else feel?
Those kinds of questions that are so important.
What were the intentions behind this action?
Was it an accident that you harmed that person
or did you fore-think that?
Those things are so core to a lot of human
morality in ways that make me think the differences
might matter.
But with respect to the brain, I don't think
we're seeing those differences come out as
of yet.
I don't know if Daphna wants to...
I think I'd just add that it's not-one question
is whether the areas exist which is important.
Some newer studies are suggesting not for
morality per se but in general, but one thing
that changes is how those areas talks each
other.
Where the connections are even in areas that
all exist across species.
And so that that turns out to be an important
dimension for understanding cognition thinking
and reasoning in general.
So there's data showing and that when evaluating
others identities, we pay more attention to
morality than memory or personality or taste
or intelligence.
And I'm wondering if it's even possible or
if it's possible to test which one of those
is actually most predictive of behavior in
some general sense?
If that's even an acute, coherent question.
And if it is, how might you approach it?
Josh, do you want to...?
I think that a lot of the discussion we've
been having with the relationship between
this idea we have of how to understand how
we ordinarily understand the self and the
science of the self.
So how people's actual behavior works, how
people actually perform behaviors.
But I think if you want to understand how
people think about the self, I don't think
that the real reason we think about the self
in the way that we do is because we have some
specialized systems for human beings in the
way that for example we may have a specialized
Department, the Department of Psychology,
that is in charge of understanding how human
beings behave.
Rather we have a general way of thinking about
things.
We just apply that thing to the self.
So in particular, we have a joke, the first
thing you are the essences of things so we
can think about what is the essence of you
know Nina's.
But we also think what is the essence of this
band?
What is the essence of the university?
What's the essence of science?
What is the essence of the United States?
And in each of those cases, we show this exact
same effect.
So if you ask people, not what is the essence
of Jim, but what's the essence of the United
States?
What's the United States really all about?
Then people have really different views about
what's good.
If say that what the United States is really
about is that thing, the thing, the thing
they think is the good thing.
And then of course the United States does
all this other stuff.
For different people, it's the opposite things
which they think is the other stuff.
But whichever is the thing they think is the
bad thing of the United States they think
that's just kind of some superficial phenomenon.
If we could get back to the essence of what
the United States is really all about, it
would be this good thing.
To thinking, maybe in response to Matt's question
is that you shouldn't think of this capacity
we have to think about the self as somehow
as if it were an attempt either successful
or failed to do the psychology of itself.
You should think of it as an application of
this much more general capacity we have to
think about essences of about what things
are really about to the particular case of
human beings.
There's one very brief addition to Matt's
question.
I mean I think and this came out in Daphna's
questions about the importance of behavior.
We can ask ourselves in each case, will a
change in moral values affect behavior more
than change in memory?
And there's not going to be a fixed answer.
There'll be certain domains where that difference
really does matter.
So we've been looking at a little bit in the
context of parole cases.
So to go back to a related case of past criminality,
our old friend Adolf Eichmann.
So suppose Eichmann had been captured in Buenos
Aires some decades later.
So he wasn't captured in the 60s, he was captured
say in the 80s and he was already experiencing
dementia.
So now you ask Eichmann, do you remember your
transgressions when you were working for the
Reich?
And he might have no memory of that.
Imagine he has no memory of that.
But imagine that he still is deeply committed
to his anti-Semitic agenda.
And now ask yourself if he were given the
opportunity to re-offend, when he re-offend?
And there it seems like the answer might be
yes.
And merely forgetting your past crimes doesn't
necessarily reduce probability of re-offense
in the same way that world reform would.
So in the context of parole right now just
doing it with hypothetical cases but we're
starting to do archive work too.
The hope is that we can see the impact.
We know that with parole decisions, change
in values really matters.
And I think the reason for that is with respect
to this particular issue of criminal behavior,
we know that that's the difference that makes
a difference.
Whereas a loss of memory or maybe even in
some cognitive capacities wouldn't necessarily
give the same reassurance.
But if I may respectfully disagree.
So what Jesse is saying, which I think is
a very reasonable hypothesis is that the reason
people do this, the reason that for example
in parole decisions people care about this
question, is because they care about behavior.
They care about whether someone is going to
re-offend.
And that would really make a lot of sense.
But I don't think that's what's going on in
this case at all.
It has nothing to do with what makes sense.
It has to do with just our general ability
to think about things and whether something
is the same thing as something else.
So say Jesse commits some crime then we find
someone and we're trying to figure out whether
that person has be convicted.
We want to ask the question, is that person
Jesse?
If it's not Jesse, if it's someone else, then
we can't convict him of the crime that Jesse
can do-that was the one who performed it.
So this study that Jesse mentioned a number
of minutes ago about someone who's either
a punk and turns into a jock or a jock who
turns into a punk, is actually a story about
this very phenomenon.
So people think of punks and jocks as equally
willing to- equally likely to commit certain
kinds of crimes.
It's not as though punks commit crimes but
jocks don't, or jocks commit crimes but punks
don't.
But if you switch between them, so say you're
a punk and you commit a crime, you're shoplifting
and then later you turn into a jock.
People think less that you should be punished.
Not because they think that now you turn into
a jock, you're less likely to shoplift again.
But because they think they can't convict
that person of the crime who is not the same
person anymore.
It's not the punk who originally committed
the crime.
Well I-we are unfortunately out of time even
though I could listen to you guys speak forever
so let's get one more huge round of applause.